-Are you ready to tear down
that wall around your heart?
Then Trump Mingle
is the dating app for you.
-I tried other dating apps.
They were sad, pathetic.
But the people on Trump Mingle
are tremendous,
just fantastic and tremendous.
-One of the great things
about Trump Mingle
is it only allows you
to list your dislikes.
-Meryl Streep is so overrated.
-Terrible in "The Iron Lady."
-And have you seen
the "Today" show ratings?
-It's unwatchable.
-And who even reads
The New York Times anymore?
-Uh, no one.
That's why it's...
-failing.
-Failing.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, failing.
-I just starting kissing her.
I couldn't even wait.
When you're a Trump Mingle user,
they let you do it.
-Other apps, they don't vet,
but Trump Mingle
has extreme vetting.
Study the world, people.
It's got a lot of bad dudes
in it.
Bad hombres, losers, haters.
But not here.
-Look, there are other apps.
Look, okay, here's the thing.
I'm smart.
I went to an Ivy League school.
You know, and this is
the best dating app.
Everyone says so.
You see, these other --
Okay, listen.
We all know what it's like.
You know,
dating is gonna be so good.
I mean, it hasn't been good.
I mean, look at our roads
and bridges.
It's a disaster.
Dating is a disaster.
You can't even get a reservation
at a good restaurant anymore.
And Putin?
Not a bad guy, believe me.
You know, I've never met him,
but I really like him.
But I don't know him,
and I've never called him.
But great guy.
-You read my mind.
-We never win anymore.
Finally, we're winning
and meeting our soul mates.
And it's all thanks
to Trump Mingle.
-We were
the only two black people.
-I couldn't be happier
about purchasing --
I'm sorry, meeting my wife
on Trump Mingle.
-Trump Mingle also offers
a 30% discount
on Russian mail-order brides
for first-time users.
So what are you waiting for?
Hurry and sign up now.
-Make America date again!
-And if you like Trump Mingle,
you'll love Bernie Connect.
-I like soup!
-Me too!
-But I don't like it
when it's too hot!
-I love you!